[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas un petit plus mais c'est un
véritable atout pour la ville c'est une
équipe qui est à partizan qui est
implanté dans tous les quartiers de
façon équitable et c'est une équipe
représentative des vies six mois et
c'est également une équipe où il y a des
gens qui sont très en service in war ou
alors de tout nouveaux vie six mois mais
qui partagent en tout cas la même vision
de la même vision de la ville de
préservation de la qualité de vie et de
son art de vivre mais aussi de son futur
[Applaudissements]
le point phare ce sera le lancement de
l'écoquartier de la remise qui bon qui a
été présenté aux habitants en décembre
mais qui devrait être exemplaire en
terme d'aménagement puisque la nature va
y ait vraiment et trouver une place
forte
le sport sera parfaitement intégré il y
aura des commerces et puis bien sûr des
modes de déplacement doux et ce sera
vraiment un quartier exemplaire et tient
tout de suite a relancé les deux cycles
de fond qu'on a abordé avec saint
quentin en yvelines en particulier comme
à la rue de la mairie ténor la
passerelle docile
alors on a fait pas mal de choses avec
eux avec des ateliers on a travaillé que
les habitants dans tout ça est pas à
remettre en route
et puis je tiens également à mettre en
place rapidement une task force comme on
dit sur le sur le problème de la
circulation pour relancer le dialogue
pour avoir un calendrier d'action qui
soit réaliste et concret il ya également
le projet du cimetière bien sûr qui
quitte à relancer et on a maintenant
toutes les études nécessaires pour
pouvoir faire des shows avec les
habitants et puis bien sûr il faut
absolument c'est une évidence trier soit
tiré les leçons par bandes de la crise
répertorié mettre en place les actions
nécessaires c'est à cette crise
sanitaire en lien évident avec la crise
économique pour que la commune joue son
rôle d'amortisseur social
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]